[Music]
hi
i'm kit ong i'm a spatial designer
that's my main profession but i also do
multi-disciplinary
design as well and i collaborated in a
lot of other
cross-disciplinary projects my design
philosophy is
art of imperfection perfection of design
this is arise from my love for natural
material or the usage of natural
material like timber
natural stones and so on in most of my
projects
and the perfection of design is because
we are
very meticulous when it comes to detail
so
for example in a special project we
would go down to the very last boat
as a designer in the build industry
sometimes we do need to
hunt for small accessories as well as
the different assortment of furnitures
and in fact tambunya building is one of
the places that we usually go to
and don't be deceived by the plain
looking building inside is an enclave of
big and small furniture companies that
sells
an area of all different types of
furniture locally made as well as
internationally imported this is a
treasure
cove for anyone not just designers
homeowners alike to look for
unique pieces of furniture as well as
accessories
the interesting part of this is that
this warehouse look alike shops
in fact are properly done up showrooms
as well so a lot of customers are able
to
actually get some kind of ideas and
mock-up by
visiting the different pockets of the
buildings
[Music]
many of singaporeans now like to dine at
the air-conditioned food courts
and even in restaurants but i think
the hawker centers are one of the charm
of singapore
food scene and one of the better design
hawker centers is in fact very near to
my home which is a rangoon garden market
and food center
so this place is well designed with a
central courtyard that allows the whole
space to be well ventilated for an unair
conditioned area
it's very airy and very comfortable to
die in and
not forgetting there are many of my
favorite foods there
this is my home at hillside since the
new normal i've started
to juggle between working from home and
from the office
in fact the house was designed as a open
concept spaces so in a sense there are
ample spaces for us to maneuver around
and to
still create that virtual individual
spaces
first thing we did is to tear down the
wall of the
very narrow terrace house so after the
war was torn down we replaced it with
giant glass doors so these are pivot
doors that can be opened fully so in the
way we
actually created a much bigger livable
space
and at the same time we also turn the
car garage
into a patio so that extended the
outdoor space
to the living spaces after a hard day's
work usually i like to hang around with
friends you know sign up for drinks or
coffee
you know and holland is one of the very
nice enclaves
what attracts me to this place is in
fact the uh eclectic
mix of new shop fronts that will pop up
every now and then
when i visited you know and one of the
favorite place in holland view that i
usually visit is a 2am desert bar
i think the unique part about 2m is that
the chef janice wong even took the
effort to redesign some of the
tablewares
to present her dessert in a unique style
and as well as to redesign
some of the papers and chairs to allow
a communal dine-in for dessert
cross-collaboration works both ways we
are all putting our
best part of our profession on the table
you know so that everyone share
knowledges
and we will cross path at some point you
know
creating new sparks for a new product
so be it whether it's spatial design or
product design
or in fact any form of design you know
so that is just a medium that we express
our
creativity in a collective manner one of
the greatest passion in life that i have
is my love for
riding so i've been riding for the past
20 years in fact
on two wheels you feel alive when the
winds are blowing against your face and
that's where you can forget
a lot of things you know and sometimes
even recompose
about a certain problem so usually late
at night sometimes just like to take the
bite out for a spin
as a designer this profession is not an
easy path
but somehow i think that one word
passion
is the one that keeps us alive that
allows us to continue to persevere
in what we like to do what we love to do
in fact this is the only viewer
that kept us going continue to be
passionate in what you are doing
i think it can move mountains
you